revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 y me acompaña en el estudio
estaba mañana el lunes como siempre
Marta Moya Marta bienvenida buena mañana
y vamos a empezar hoy comentando una
investigación que hace el medio
estadounidense New York Times sobre los
presuntos crímenes de guerra que habían
cometido los ucranianos con el asesinato
de soldados rusos desarmados en una
aldea de la región de luggans Marta
precisamente el gobierno ruso pidió hoy
una investigación internacional sobre
este caso ante la dinacción precisamente
de la comunidad sobre todo de occidente
Buenos días vamos a empezar con esta
este análisis y esta investigación
visual que hace el New York Times que
titula vídeos sugieren que soldados
rusos cautivos fueron asesinados a
quemarropa todo esto pasó en la aldea de
matifka una aldea en la región de lugans
que la región del lombas que fue anexada
a Rusia a finales de septiembre
recordemos estos vídeos aparecieron en
las redes sociales durante la última
semana y ha surgido el debate sobre Si
las fuerzas ucranianas cometieron
crímenes de guerra asesinando a estos
soldados rusos o si actuaron bajo el
precepto de la legítima defensa después
de que uno de estos soldados rusos
atacara a los ucranianos mientras se
rendían estos vídeos Fueron verificados
por el New York Times aunque no se puede
saber cómo ni por qué los soldados rusos
al menos 11 fueron asesinados esto se ha
utilizado por supuesto también como un
arma de propaganda a un lado y al otro
del conflicto Ucrania utilizó primero
los vídeos diciendo que bueno elogiando
la destreza de sus fuerzas armadas y
Rusia alentó a esa línea dura que pide
una escalada del conflicto no se acusan
ambos de crímenes de guerra Rusia por
disparar a prisioneros que estaban
desarmados y Ucrania Porque estos
soldados rusos abrieron fuego mientras
los soldados estaban rindiendo Ucrania
recuperó esta aldea de maquifca en los
últimos meses después de anexionarse la
región por parte de Rusia a finales de
septiembre y los soldados ucranianos se
ven en estos vídeos como empiezan a
disparar y los soldados rusos están en
unas letrinas En una granja se corta el
vídeo y después aparecen los soldados
rusos todos tirados en el suelo y solo
dos de ellos se mueven bueno Marta
seguimos en Ucrania porque tras los
ataques de los últimos días alrededor de
la planta nuclear de esa polilla el
medio de economic se publicó un informe
en el que habla el tira y afloja que hay
en torno a esta estratégica
infraestructura no así es si lo titula
así una alarmante tira y afloja por una
central nuclear ucraniana recordemos que
es la planta nuclear más grande de toda
Europa que los rusos atacaron a esta
central nuclear en marzo y desde
entonces han utilizado la intimidación
el Sabotaje incluso la violencia para
ejercer el control técnico y
administrativo de planta no la hacen
servir en estos momentos como una base
militar donde hay según este artículo 10
economes unos 500 soldados rusos que
están atrincherados con sus vehículos
blindados en la planta y además utilizan
también los búnkers que hay construidos
en caso de un accidente nuclear sostiene
este artículo de Diego economics que los
rusos quieren conectar la central
nuclear de zaporiya a la de crimea para
robar la electricidad de Ucrania pero
que no está siendo posible porque las
centrales eléctricas están muy dañadas
por los combates de los últimos meses en
concreto también de las últimas semanas
y días Este está central de zaporiya
tiene a 3000 empleados ucranianos de los
cuales 200 se habrían firmado un
contrato con una empresa energética rusa
de Nueva creación que les ofrece mejores
salarios y primas Marta continuamos con
un medio estadounidense de intercept que
se pregunta si el gobierno pudiera
entonces enviar drones de alta
tecnología para ayudar a las tropas de
kiev si Raúl y se pregunta byden venderá
drones avanzados a Ucrania sostiene este
artículo desde intercept que tanto Rusia
como Ucrania han venido utilizando
drones de bajo costo en el curso de la
guerra pero ahora mismo la
administración vaiden se plantea así
vender drones Grey Eagle que son drones
capaces de disparar cuatro misiles en
simultáneo y es una variante que ya han
utilizado en Estados Unidos en otros
conflictos en el norte de África o en
Afganistán estos drones tienen una
sofisticada tecnología de reconocimiento
e inteligencia Y son capaces de
permanecer en el aire hasta 24 horas de
manera ininterrumpida hasta la fecha
Estados Unidos ya ha brindado otros
drones a Ucrania pero no este tipo de
Calibre porque temen que esto pueda
generar una escalada en el conflicto e
incluso que uno de estos drones falle y
pueda acabar en manos rusas que sean
conscientes y sean capaces de reconocer
esta alta tecnología ha habido intentos
varios de hecho a lo largo de estos
últimos meses de que se materializa y
esta venta de drones de alta tecnología
pero de momento la clase Blanca es
reticente cerramos nuestra revista de
prensa del día de hoy Marta repasando
algunos obituarios y también columnas de
opinión de la destacada que destaca la
presa Argentina mejor de la que fuera
Eve de una fini la fundadora del
movimiento de las madres la Plaza de
Mayo Sí una de las fundadoras no y un
referente de esta lucha de las madres
argentinas por recuperar o dar bueno que
las autoridades rindieran
responsabilidades por las muertes de sus
hijos durante la dictadura de Jorge
Videla Eve de bonafini fue una de estas
grandes figuras del movimiento de las
mujeres de la Plaza de Mayo se unió tras
la desaparición de sus dos hijos y dice
por ejemplo la nación de Argentina que
fue combativa al extremo y verborrágica
por convicción y que también no ahorró
esfuerzos para seleccionar a sus
enemigos Por ejemplo el medio Clarín
destaca que fue una mujer Dual y que
representó a dos argentinas muy
distintas Por una parte fue víctima de
la represión policial durante la
reivindicaciones de la Plaza de Mayo y
por otra parte pasó a una sumisión
destaca este artículo de Clarín a la
política más rapaz no poniendo en duda
la propia democracia y alineándose mucho
con el kirchnerismo y por finalizar
destacamos una columna de opinión a modo
de obituario que hace página 12 que dice
Eve la voz y la injuria y dije que Eve
de bonafini Levantó su voz contra el
silencio y reivindiqué reivindicó la
dignidad del país que sigue y será por
siempre la conciencia de los silenciados
la palabra de los asesinados y la
irreverencia de los que no se sometieron
al poder y que reclamó para sí misma el
derecho irrenunciable a injuriar a
quienes desaparecieron a Marta como
siempre Gracias por toda la información
de revista de prensa mañana Por supuesto
con más Gracias Raúl